you ever played mary [ __ ] kill yes we're
gonna play mary [ __ ] kill okay what
what's that what's that what's that look
mary [ __ ] kill we just did a version of
that yeah it's true
no she didn't kill anyone no
mary [ __ ] hill eminem
drake
kanye oh [ __ ] you really threw me
cause i mean
i would have killed drake even though i
love his music i hate how he is at nba
games because it's just so annoying that
he just yells at players and it [ __ ]
irks me so fast he's like a coach and
he's like a gnome he shows up at every
event you want to be at and has the best
[ __ ] seats ever so you can hold him
what a dick but i'll marry drake and
i'll tell you why no no no yeah i'll
marry drake i'll tell you why because he
spent like 860 million dollars to have
his house taken off of google maps which
i thought was amazing they had to undig
all of his wires it was i thought that
was amazing that's how much it costs
that seems like an aggressive amount of
marriage you can look that up married i
didn't negotiate so you're marrying
drake i'm [ __ ] eminem only because we
did the music
video together we were in bed together
and i just don't think he's the type of
person that really wants somebody around
all the time so that's where the
marriage thing and i'm straight up
murdering kanye
and i'm doing it
to protect him and all this drama that's
going to be going on he has gone over
that and now he's buddied up with
antonio brown and they're even talking
enough [ __ ] that they could buy the
denver broncos like both of you two walk
it off walk it off walk it off
you're marrying drake yeah you're
banging eminem because of the close
relationship that you've had yeah
literally in bed yeah i don't want to
pressure him about a relationship but i
and i because if i marry drake get onto
sex with him most married couples don't
have sex anymore once they get married
anyway got it and then you're just going
to straight up i'm going to go to all
the games you're going to kill all the
games
you're on team you're on team pete or
team kim not team kanye
i'm
i don't love kim because i don't like
the falsehood of her actually saying
this sex tape was leaked she got five
million for it it launched her career
like her mom put that [ __ ] out there
with people
against the law in the united states
after the pam anderson uh movie was
leaked to do anything like that so
there's that chris jenner i just don't
like this kind of drama around the kids
and all of that right i just don't from
what i hear i've never met pete davidson
but everybody says he's just like the
nicest person he's so easy going and i'm
happy for her that she's got somebody
light-hearted and fun around her right
now but i'd like the drama to stop him
burying him in a music video yeah weird
kanye is getting weird
[Music]